philosophers and intellectuals more  generally have a bad reputation when it  comes to their bodies it seems as if  taking the life of the mind seriously  also means not being too interested in  cultivating physical health and prowess  the choice seems to be between  intelligence and brawn but if you look  back to ancient Greece the situation was  really quite different there  philosophers took a deep interest in  exercise some of Socrates's most  important dialogues take place in  gymnasiums which were seen as places for  the exercise of the mind as well as the  body  Apollo Greek god of truth and insight  was also always depicted as physically  very fit it's in the spirit of Greek  philosophy that at the school of life  we've invited Socrates to come and  exercise with one of the UK's foremost  fitness trainers Steve halsell to remind  himself that a healthy mind truly does  require a healthy body  you  you